i hear your hobby these days though i
mean i know ever all of us been in
pandemic whatever now i hear your
hobbies
lately have been kind of nerdy so i'm
very excited to know i feel like my
hobbies were
always nerdy i did grow up like reading
graphic novel
novels and my my older sister was really
into x-men comics and so
yeah i got into comics young um
i love x-men i'm a big reader also just
in general
so i'm not usually on tv a lot like
watching tv or watching movies i do a
lot of reading
super dorky me too one of my favorite
things that everyone gives me a hard
time about
and i i'm dying to go there as soon as i
can
um to harry potter land and universal i
am
a crazy i'm a gryffindor
avi you're you're a gryffindor yeah i'm
a gryffindor okay i have the whole thing
do you have a cape i have a cake the
scarf the wine
i have everything again i'm literally
i just took my kids to legoland and i
will tell you this i am the child of the
group i have a
i have a five and six-year-old yeah i am
the toddler of the group i get
so excited like way more excited than
they get it's actually
super divisive like when you do your
house which house you're in
like amongst your family because anyone
that gets sorted into
slytherin is very upset about it i was
kind of i love gryffindor i was kind of
bummed because i was so basic about it i
i knew i was going to be a gryffindor i
thought i don't know i was kind of like
all right
courageous adventurous she's like that's
harry these are the things we are
do you get more excited than your boys
or they they don't care yet they're too
young
oh see my kids are kind of but they
understand that i'm obsessed so every
gift they get me for mother's day or
christmas is harry potter themed so i
get
harry potter mugs or harry potter
journals or i got like a quill for my
birthday i love that
yeah oh i full-on got an owl whatever
not a real one
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help